all right guys
bang bang i've got a super awesome guest
today i've got lauren here with me thank
you so much for doing this
oh thanks for having me i'm so excited
to be here all right so
you work with the new york yankees and
you essentially try to help
uh the entire um you know kind of base
of athletes get better
mentally before we get into that let's
talk about kind of your background
where do you grow up how do you get into
this line um
what do you go to school for and like
why are you so interested in kind of the
mental performance
of individuals uh so i'll start from the
beginning i grew up
in a town called placentia california
it's in southern california
um i currently reside in northern
california um
and i it was all sports in my household
all the time growing up and i think
that's what kind of drew me to this i
mean i've always loved sports and so i
think
i always knew i wanted to work in sports
but i didn't know even sport psychology
existed
until my senior year of college actually
i was getting my degree in kinesiology
and thinking i wanted to go on into
physical therapy because it was the only
thing i could really see
and interested me in terms of sports and
i got injured my senior year of college
and i had a little bit more time i
played soccer in college i should
mention
and i wasn't able to play anymore so i
was still able to be on the sidelines
but my role changed vastly so i decided
to take an
elective course and i found sports
psychology
and i just totally fell in love with it
and i think the reason why is because i
was the athlete that needed it
i was that athlete that would constantly
get in my own way
and would believe my limiting thoughts
and
believe these negative thoughts and
allowed fear to kind of take the wheel
many times and so i think when i was in
that course i had so many light bulb
moments and i thought
what would my soccer career i mean i was
no
you know mia ham carly lloyd abby
wambach but i
thought like what would my soccer career
look like
would i have enjoyed it more if i would
have had these mental skills
kind of in my arsenal and so that's when
i decided
you know wow this is this is something i
could do to help others where they
wouldn't look back on their career and
say man what if i had these skills what
if
what would it have looked like so that's
kind of what led me into that and i've
been
super passionate really ever since then
and i think the biggest reason was
because
i never understood why somebody with
talent
wasn't successful and
i again i was no i i didn't have extreme
talent i i was
i was i was okay but um i thought why
wasn't i having success when i knew i
could do things that i just wasn't
living up to that
and so i think that was what really drew
me into this field and
and then it began to make sense about
how these coping strategies
allow people to perform at their best
when
it matters most in under extreme
circumstances
got it and so as a mental conditioning
coach like talk
through just like what does that really
entail what is the relationship you have
with athletes what is kind of the
day-to-day look like
and kind of where do you focus uh in
terms of actually working with these
people
yeah so um really what we do our job is
to
in teach mental skills and help our
athletes develop mental skills mental
toughness
so they can be their best regardless of
circumstance
so they can show up at the best level no
matter what is thrown at them
no matter what cards they are dealt and
i think a lot of people think you know
oh pro athlete they're really good
because
they can change their circumstances well
they're not known for
necessarily changing and magically
changing the situation they're in
they're known for responding at a high
level
regardless of what is thrown their way
and so i think it's our job
to not only be able to recognize some of
those skills that might be lacking or
areas of improvement in terms of
the mental side and so my relationship
with my athletes
is well i should start by saying the
culture
at the yankees is you don't have to be
sick to get better
i think whenever you put this idea like
mental in front of anything
there's kind of this stigma attached and
they i walked into a really great
culture um
when i first started with the inks four
years ago and
that was already established but i think
sometimes
um if there's kind of a one-person show
and you take on too much
you are limited to taking the worst
cases first
which ultimately builds this culture of
oh you must have a problem if you're
going to talk to that person
and so i think that that's one of the
things that i'm really lucky that i got
to walk into that culture and so
we work with athletes that are not only
performing their best
but and or performing their worst but
everything in between
and um and we do that through first the
most important thing is building a
relationship with those people because
in our athletes because you wouldn't
tell anybody something super personal
about you if you didn't know them
you didn't trust them so that's probably
the most important is to build that
trust and relationship
first and then you know we work with
them with whether it's a one-on-one
session whether it's group sessions
you know a lot of them take place like
in the dugout you know in the outfield
you know when we're
chagging balls during vp you know it's
it's kind of it's it's not the
traditional
sit in the office you know and schedule
an appointment and after an hour you're
out it's like
when sometimes they're five minutes
before you know before they go out um
to the field it just it kind of depends
so it's a little bit um
more casual in that nature but that's
kind of what it looks like
so i want to talk about baseball
specifics first and then we'll kind of
extrapolate some of the learnings there
to
other aspects but um in terms of
baseball
who needs the most help is it hitters is
it pitchers
is it everyone in between is there a
difference like how do you just think
about
uh if you're like hey you know i'm going
to the ballpark today
uh is there a certain framework you use
as to
who to help uh or who to evaluate
um first or kind of take priority
um well i think it's i think asking like
who needs more
mental toughness is the same as asking
who needs more physical strength
you know it's it's very similar it's
everybody needs some i mean here's the
thing
elite athletes what it really boils down
to is their ability to adapt to any
situation that they're putting
that's like that one thing that makes
really
like a good athlete elite and that could
be a physical adaptation
you know when you have when you have a
certain level of strength you're able to
adapt in certain ways
that maybe somebody that doesn't have
that strength could
and same with the mental side is the
adaptation mentally emotionally
being able to adapt to maybe either
negative thoughts
fear self-doubt adversity um feeling
like
oh i've got it i'm gonna cruise now like
being able to override those default
settings
all comes through with that mental
strength and i don't think
there's a position that necessarily like
needs more
than somebody else i just think it
varies by the person
some people they are naturally born with
a little bit more resilience than others
but
also the more important piece is that
our brain is so plastic
in terms that it can change over time
and so it's also something
that can be built and developed over
time
and so i don't necessarily think that
there's one that needs it more than the
other but in terms of
prioritizing um again we don't
necessarily prioritize somebody who's
struggling
terribly versus somebody who's having
the best
the best like year of their life because
that would go against our core belief
which is you don't have to be sick to
get better
and so for us it's it's really of course
there are situations especially when
they
turn when they cross the threshold of
mental performance into
um into a clinical um issue
or a clinical symptom sign or symptom
then we
then that might be something we want to
address immediately and there's
i guess urgency might change but in
terms of one being more important the
other
i i don't necessarily agree with that
got it and you mentioned earlier kind of
like being
born a certain way how much of it is
literally you're just born more mentally
tough or uh
or have certain kind of predispositions
versus
uh maybe it's your environment as a
young kid or the way that you trained
or something in your life that has made
you either more or less
mentally tough or more resilient or more
adaptable uh to kind of a changing
environment
yeah i think that yes there there is
some of us
some of us are predisposed to some of
these things like to be
we to be more resilient more tough and
then you want to throw in
uh your environment that you grew up and
sure that does have an impact as well
but i think the coolest part about the
mental side is that it can be grown and
developed
it's just like people that you know are
naturally athletic they come out with
these like
they never work out but they're just
jacked and you're like why who are you
but it's like that it's yes you can have
that but then also
it's this other piece that you can
continue to build
you can continue to and even if you
you're born without it
it's all it is is we have these default
settings in our brain it's like an
iphone
except the difference is you can't just
like download a new app for positive
thinking right
and the way that we download these new
these new kind of neural pathways is
through repetition
and so every time you repeat something
you increase the you increase the
chances that you're going to repeat him
again
and that's how we develop habits and we
are
a product of them you know your weight
is a product of your eating habits your
finances are a product of your spending
habits and uh that
james clear talks about this in his book
and
so i really think that you know a while
yes that does play
some of a role that even if you don't
have any of it
you can still become mentally tough it
is not a limiting factor
yeah and what seems to be really
interesting about this is that
repetition right and so
uh probably the most popular question
that i got when i asked for questions
for uh talking to you was
how do i become mentally tougher like
what are the things that either you do
for a baseball player a business
executive i don't know maybe if they
even change depending on
kind of what you know occupation
somebody holds but like
what are those things that maybe aren't
the um you know silver bullet and kind
of the one size fits all
but just things that people can do at
home that really drive repetition and
ultimately increase mental resiliency or
toughness
yeah so we have these kind of big like
terms that we hear often in sports and
even in
i mean business and just successful
individuals is this idea of
kind of consistency so i think i
actually talked about this a couple
weeks ago
um in one of my videos because i think
especially with the new year everybody's
creating these new
goals and you know everybody i mean
we've all been there before where we've
like set a goal
in like a month in it's nowhere to be
found like we have we've just
completely eliminated it and i think one
of the
tools that has always helped me and this
is kind of one of the foundational
pieces of mental toughness in my mind
in terms of building it is consistency
is repetition
and so i call it the lowest common
denominator that a lot of times we go in
we're all or nothing either we
if our goal is to go to the gym for an
hour three days a week
if we don't go to the gym and we're not
there for an hour or we don't have time
to go for an
hour then we're just not going to go at
all and
in my mind i like to think of i don't
want to eliminate consistency
let's just lessen intensity if we can't
go to the gym
maybe the gym is closed or if uh it's
raining outside so you can't go on the
run you want
do a hit workout for 10 minutes inside
or do abs for five minutes
we're lowering intensity but we're
remaining consistent
and so consistency long-term consistency
trump's short-term intensity and bruce
lee said that and i think it's so
important because
little by little a little bit comes a
lot and so when we can string together
these really tiny wins
every single day they don't have to be
big they can be really
small and i love this analogy that um
james clear uses and he talks about if a
plane takes off in
la and its goal is to land in new york
but it adjusts the nose just three
degrees south when it first adjusts it
it's only you know i don't know a couple
feet you know it's not it's not a big
difference
but when it's multiplied across the
united states you end up landing in
washington dc
and so that is how these small tiny
changes
impact our lives over time and everybody
overestimates what they can do
in a day and they underestimate how much
they can do in a month
in a year and so that's where i would
write i would say like one of the
biggest foundational pieces is being
consistent and so one of the things that
you can do to be consistent in
is increasing our awareness you can't
change anything if you're not aware of
it
so first thing is awareness and one of
the ways that i do this with a lot of my
athletes is journaling
it's one of those like really really uh
a lot of people think it's boring a lot
of people may think it's mundane it's
not sexy it's not like
super cool but it's it works it's simple
and it's effective
and so one of the things that you can do
is ask yourself these three questions i
ask myself these three questions
every single day first i write about my
day because it just helps me get it out
then i ask myself these three questions
one what went well today or what did i
do well today
one i start with that because our brain
defaults to the negative
it defaults to like what went wrong or
how can i improve
so i want to start by kind of choosing
like what went well today no matter how
bad your day is something
you can name either went well or that
you did well
and then two what can i improve because
if if you're not improving we can become
stagnant
and so we want to continue to evolve and
change over time so what
can i improve or what can i do better
and then three what did i learn like
what's the lesson that i pulled from
this like what was the final piece that
i can then take and apply to my next day
so as we do that we can start to learn
these patterns of behavior
and once we see these patterns like oh
wow i continuously say i need to improve
this
i need to put some more time into that
or wow that's a strength of mine i keep
talking about that
and we start to learn these patterns
then we can start to decide what we're
going to do about them
yeah and as you're talking about this
consistency i think that uh you're dead
on in terms of there's almost this
compounding effect right if you keep
doing little things day in day out they
definitely compound that's
true of building a business and kind of
compounding revenue that's true of
developing a skill
it's true of creating content on the
internet or literally playing baseball
at the highest levels and trying to win
a world series
um at the same time uh that consistency
over long periods of time
um it reminds me a lot of like the long
baseball season right so they play
you know literally uh 182 games and
uh it can really wear out people and so
is there this belief
that um there's almost like this journey
where people will be at their highest
mental peak at a certain point then
they'll go through kind of these troughs
and
and they'll kind of fluctuate back and
forth and maybe you almost want to
have them as you're hitting the playoffs
being kind of mental
fitness or shape or is the belief that
no actually you can keep some you know
pretty persistent level
of mental toughness and kind of mental
acuity and so
we don't want a lot of variability it's
just let's keep the same level
uh throughout the entire season how do
you think about that the consistency
over
long periods of time whether it's a
project and a business or
a long baseball season or something like
that well i think that
you know you cannot improve
consistency unless you're consistent
with that thing
so when we start when i talk about the
lowest common denominator i talk about
you know you can't improve a habit
unless you have one and so if you
if we first establish it at the most
basic level then we can improve from
there and so i think
um yes i think that when it comes to
term consistency
um especially over 182 games season
um yeah there's going to be days where
you're not going to feel like it
where it's going to be tough and there's
going to be days where you're going to
need some time you're going to need to
take some time for you
and that's where that kind of continuum
of intensity and consistency
really pays off is that you know you're
not going to have 100 every day
you know nobody has that but it's
can you still show up when you don't
feel like it
can you still perform when you don't
feel like it the thing is it's going to
be easy to just say i'm not
going to do it doesn't mean that you
don't need days off doesn't mean that
self-care doesn't matter all that stuff
matters
all that stuff i think it i mean we're
talking about a human
here yes they're athletes but they're
humans at the core
and so if we don't take care of the
person first
yeah we can burn out super easily so i
think that
but having said that i should say that a
lot of these guys we look at you know
kobe bryant we look at um you know
lebron we look at some of the best
in the world and they are insanely
consistent like derek jeter for instance
i've never worked with him but it was
way before me
but um but he walked into the locker
room the same way he walked out
he was insanely consistent and now there
are times where
um we're not going to be perfect and i
think people people mistake consistency
with perfection
consistency is a average over time
and i think the best athletes they make
mistakes
but they don't make mistakes twice
because if you make a mistake once
okay but you make this a mistake twice
now you're creating a habit in the
opposite direction
and so i think that's the really
important part is that it's okay if you
make a mistake
it's okay if you're if you don't follow
through one day but
how quickly can you respond so it's more
of the response to those downs
than it is to not having them at all
yeah and speaking of
uh kind of downs one of the things
that's uh unique for
sports and maybe for some of the people
who listen to this who are
high profile investors or founders
uh is there's also media scrutiny on top
of just the performance so obviously the
new york yankees is like the perfect
example where
uh you play in new york and if they
believe that you have even the slightest
weakness or
uh the slightest kind of bad street uh
they will write about it and they will
not
you know kind of be uh apologetic about
it um
how do you kind of talk through with
players and maybe
you know founders and investors can
learn from this as well like you have to
go to work and perform
but also then you have this external
scrutiny that you have to deal with it's
almost like
you know whether you're doing well or
not and so there's this mental
uh kind of conditioning and strength
that you have to have yourself
but then you also have to deal with what
other people think and so how do you
kind of
help people navigate uh the the
difference between those two things
uh yet they're still related yeah well i
think the first thing is knowing
what fuels you okay we have people that
um that totally shut off social media
completely or
any kind of media at all because it
becomes a huge distraction
and then and i you know i'm thinking of
you know there's lots of players that do
that and then when it comes to the other
side like i think of people like michael
phelps who
would print out the credit critiques and
he would put it in his locker
and so i just think you first thing is
to know which one you
are because the point is not to avoid it
necessarily but to optimize
performance and so sometimes what that
means is learning what to ignore
learning what things that you need to
cut out and for a certain amount of time
so i think number one it we have to know
that and then number two
your opinion of you is so much more
powerful
than anyone else's opinion of you
everybody's gonna have one
and especially like you said like the
yankees fans if you do well
they love you if you don't do well
like they hate you and so that's the
important piece is to know that
it's it's easy for our attention to be
pulled to these highs and lows
but what we that's i think the the
challenge
of the this mental conditioning is
choosing not to be pulled choosing not
to believe those negative thoughts
because
just because somebody has a thought or
you have a thought it doesn't make it
true
and so one of the things that we talk
about is like doubting your doubts like
not necessarily like just falling into
that so
number one is knowing which one works
for you and number two focusing on your
opinion of you
and number three what is your process i
think a lot of people
they go our every every player to some
degree goes through a slump
right they they have a period of time
where they're not great
and what we tend to do is we focus on
this outcome
and i think a lot of times the fear
comes from either
the fear of failure fear of failing or
the repercussions from failing the
articles being written what people are
going to say
and where our focus needs to shift is
from instead of the outcome because a
lot of times what we do is we will
throw away any process anything that got
us to be successful
just to try and be successful once
because we want we crave it so bad but
what we're doing is we're creating bad
habits and so instead i would rather
focus
whether you're an investor whether
you're an athlete
or anything else that focus on the
quality of what you do
versus the only the outcome of what you
do
so from an instance we redefine success
so i had an athlete who
you know was really really struggling at
the plate
and i asked him i said all right so if
you if success couldn't be defined as
getting a hit
or hitting a home run whatever that is
for you how would you define it
meaning if you went up to the plate and
you did a b and c
that would mean that you're successful
regardless of the outcome and we came up
with three things that he could control
we have to redefine success to be within
our control
so it became you know making a good
swing decision being on time and having
an external focus
if he did those three things he said
more than likely i am successful and i
would say i did
everything i possibly could i said great
that is how we redefined it and so
it's very easy what's going to happen is
our default setting wants to go to the
outcome because that's the thing we're
fearing
but we need to pull ourselves back to
our process and go
all right how can i redefine success to
be within my control
and then evaluate your performance based
on that yeah
it's so true and sports is a great
example of this you know there's plenty
of coaches who kind of say focus on the
process and the outcome takes care of
itself
right one of my favorite examples
is i think it might be bill walsh or
somebody
talks all the time about like look every
play in football uh is drawn up to be a
touchdown
like there's no play that somebody draws
up and it's like hey we're only gonna
you know get one yard here like no it's
a touchdown every single time
uh and it's dependent on 11 people on
the field all doing
their job and when a play doesn't score
touchdowns usually because somebody one
of the three people
or one of the 11 people didn't do their
job right and so i think that focusing
on that process
uh is really important i want to talk
about uh kind of these
hacks or education um two of my favorite
things in the world to tell people
just that really highlight how powerful
the mind is
how much it can change um kind of the
rest of your life
is uh one there's been a bunch of
studies that if you just sit
and you smile like a real smile uh for
60 seconds it can drastically change
your mood or it can put you into a much
more kind of positive
uh mindset and the second thing is uh if
you when you wake up in the morning
rather than go read
negative headlines if you get up and you
read three positive headlines you don't
have to even read the article just the
headlines themselves
you're drastically more likely at the
end of the day to say that you had a
good day rather than a bad day
and so those are you know kind of cheesy
positive mindset type things that
there's pretty much academic studies
around
are there similar types of hacks or
little things that people can take away
from our conversation
that you're like look you know here's
something that we tell athletes that
they can do that's kind of a quick five
minute or less thing
that can either help them refocus or
help them kind of remind themselves of
what their
their goal is or kind of get through a
moment where they might not have mental
strength but is there any kind of hacker
or a thing that you guys really kind of
harp on
yeah and and i love those those studies
that you mentioned
because it's what's happening and i
think why some of us maybe feel it's
kind of cheesy is because we can't see
the changes happening in our brain when
we do those things
and um one of the ones that i actually
really like is
actually a study done by amy cuddy a
really famous one about um
about body language and a lot of times
you know we believe that
or i mean it's true that i mean our
thoughts can influence how we feel and
how we feel can influence our physiology
and that can influence our actions
but what is also true is that your body
language could also influence how you
feel and can influence your thoughts
and so by simply holding a power pose
which is like those
the poses of like winning you know when
you have your hands in the air like
superman there's like all these
different poses
when you hold it for a couple of minutes
what you're doing is you're creating the
biology of courage
in your brain and so the you know
different chemicals are being suppressed
and different ones are being secreted
and so that's one way
that um you can actually create this
kind of biology of courage is that
you know there's again there's this idea
that like your actions and your thoughts
and your feelings
all have to interact and i just don't
believe that
you know everyone's like oh just fake it
till you make it and i just think that's
bs
it doesn't work for me some it may work
for some but it doesn't work for me and
the way that i look at it is is you can
feel one way
you can think one way and you can act
completely independently of that
you can feel unconfident you can
think oh gosh i'm nervous like i don't
know if i can do this
and then you can hold yourself with
confidence and you can act based on
what you know is right and so feelings
and
actions don't have to match to co-exist
and so i think one of the things that we
can do is remind ourselves to take
the right action which is hold yourself
with confidence because i'll tell you
right now
a hitter walks up and he steps into the
box and he's got bad body language
the pitcher and the catcher are like
game over game over
and so it's an advantage to the other
team when you're doing that
and i also think um and then what you're
also doing is you're creating uh
you know that it's working opposite
right different hormones are being
secreted that wouldn't if you were
holding yourself in a certain position
so
i would say number one is you know you
may not
feel confident you don't have to feel
confident to look confident and so hold
yourself
you know carry yourself like a champion
hold yourself with your with your head
high and your shoulders back
um and then the second another one that
i really like
is um is really calming ourselves down
using our breath
i mean that's one way if you want to
control yourself
when you're feeling out of control start
by controlling your breathing that's one
of the like kind of the dominoes to
controlling our physiology
that when you start to control your
breathing a lot of things in our body
just
sort of begin to kind of match that
cadence
so we can really just start by
controlling our breath and controlling
our breathing
and then i would say the third one is
is the the mindset between confidence
a threat mindset versus a con or um
sorry challenge mindset
um when we use something as a threat
our body responds to a threat
so what happens is our lungs start to
constrict our blood vessels constrict
our breath shortens and our heart rate
just starts
you know pounding like crazy and our
heart rate very variability actually
goes down
where when you simply view something as
a challenge like
i got this like or you know like bring
it on like it's not you're not saying
it's easy
but you're willing to take it or face it
head on and you're not avoiding it the
opposite actually happens our body
responds to prepare you to meet that
moment
and so our lungs actually they expand
and our blood vessels they dilate and
our heart rate their
variability goes up so we're getting
more oxygenated blood
to the rest of our body which increases
our decision-making and our ability to
see clearly
and so just by simply looking at
something
and something that would you might be
feeling nervous just reminding and
telling yourself
hey this is a challenge like let's go
this is my body telling me i'm ready
what it does is you're going to also
change your physiology and change how
your body responds yeah and part this i
think that's really interesting is that
you're talking about you know when the
batter's walking up to the batter's box
uh that's all in game or in season
uh one of the things that uh is
fascinating about sports specifically is
there's kind of a start and an end date
to the season so you can take a player
and say hey you've really got to be at
the top of your mental game you've got
to
kind of do all the physiological things
to make sure that you're putting
yourself in the best position you've got
to control your breath like all of these
things you're talking about
and you're going to do that from the
start of the season to the end of the
season
when the off season comes is there still
a like very fanatical focus on doing
those same things and so it's kind of
like
you never let your guard down you kind
of stay on edge and kind of have that
advantage
or do you find that actually um this is
somewhat laborious for
uh athletes to do and so therefore like
they almost want to break
uh in the off season and they kind of go
away and you've got to almost build the
muscle back up it's you know
similar to uh weightlifting for example
some people will go away and then when
they come back they've actually got to
get back in shape a little bit in the
preseason
like how does the in-season versus
off-season work
uh when it comes to mental conditioning
and kind of mental strength
yeah well i i definitely think that
there's
you know it doesn't mean you can't take
a break like during off season you know
guys usually take you know four weeks or
you know whatever it looks like
depending on your position um
and that's okay you know taking a break
from it all and just you know getting
away for a while is fine
however the way that i look at it is you
don't just
you don't just body language isn't just
for in-game
you know body language does not just
exist in baseball or
in sports it exists everywhere and so i
think that
the skill of body language doesn't
change just because you're in
season i think that there's other ways
that you can practice it so for instance
i
my husband and i like laugh about this
because we didn't realize we were both
doing this
but um we were watching the world series
and both of us were getting really
nervous like you know when you're
even when you're watching a movie like
your body responds as if like you're a
part of it
and we were both doing breathing
exercises to slow ourselves down and we
i was like oh my gosh we are such nerds
but we we didn't realize we were both
doing it at the same time
what is he is he also uh in like mental
conditioning
no he's a professional golfer okay all
right so you just thought of everything
you just told him everything that he's
supposed to be doing and he listens
well he doesn't really listen to me but
he listens to a lot of my colleagues
that are really brilliant
but either way we were just cracking up
because i was like you do that too
so we practice it even in things like i
now notice
when my heart rate goes up and in
anything
you know whether it's getting on a
podcast to talk to you or whether it's
i'm about to give a presentation
or you know whether i'm going to play
pick up soccer and i haven't touched a
ball in
six years or whatever it is that for me
is it's pressure moments i'm not just
saying
the moment in a game i'm saying pressure
moments in general
because that skill is universal not just
in sport but in life and business and
everything
and so i actually what we do with our
athletes if they can't play we find
different ways where they can use these
techniques
whether it is in the weight room and one
of the ways that we can even do this
when you're not
you know in game is you know we may not
be able to create the same pressure in
terms of a situation but we can create
the same
physiological response meaning they can
do a couple sprints
and then get in the box their heart rate
is jacked up
they're having a hard time breathing
so how can you then slow yourself down
and get control of that
even though we're not in a pressure
situation we are having our body act as
if it is
and so now we're having to retrain that
response and so i think
you know a lot of our athletes they may
take some time off but they're lifting
heavy in the off season
they're getting this is their time to
lift heavy and get strong
because they can't lift heavy in during
season so
i think this is another aspect where
you're still working on it
throughout the off season even as little
as what you can and cannot control i
can't control that i'm
you know we don't have a season right
now i can't control that i can't you
know
hit against live pitching but i can
control
and then fill in the blank and so i
think that there's a lot of
opportunities to still use it and to
still build it in the off season
what's the upside of stress one of the
things that has
kind of been talked about more and more
i think in the uh investing in business
community
certainly by a couple of books have been
written is the upside of stress
how do you think about that in terms of
trying to put
athletes in stressful situations
intentionally is it
using just ones that naturally occur as
teaching moments and then kind of what
are the conclusions
of hey here's the positive side of going
through these stressful moments
yeah first of all great book uh by kelly
mcgonagall the upside of stress
love it um i there so there's a couple
things but the way i kind of look at
really difficult situations is
our life like we can't avoid stress like
a lot of us like i want to eliminate it
and i'm like okay
well sure you might be able to eliminate
some but you're not going to eliminate
all and so
i actually think our a lot of our time
is wasted on trying to like eliminate
it uh because we're we're just not gonna
eliminate everything every bit of it so
i care more about how our relationship
with it
because like if you think about your
relationship with you know people
we build that when we're around them
when we you know we invest time in them
and so my question i guess the audience
would be what is your relationship with
stress
do you have a good relationship with
stress like when you are able to respond
well when you're faced with it
or you have a bad relationship do you
like retreat do you
avoid it do you uh does it impact your
ability to do what you do best
and so that i would say that stress can
be really really good in
so many ways um because it can really
push us past our comfort zone and it can
be a really good signal for growth
um so i would not i would never tell
anybody to avoid stress i would just
tell them to
to look into like what their
relationship is with it
and i think that we you know we can't
expect athletes or
our employees or anybody to respond well
when they're under pressure when they're
under stress when they're faced with
adversity or obstacles
if we haven't trained them like one of
the things i it makes me laugh every
single time is like if you go to like a
kid's soccer game
and the parents are yelling like relax
and you're like
never in the history of relaxing has
anyone relaxed because someone screamed
at you to relax
like never so my question always is how
do you
have you ever taught them how and the
question is usually no
or i'm sorry the answer is usually no
and so i would say
your response to stress matters more so
if you're somebody that
wants to like immediately you want to
respond emotionally
it's kind of this reactive nature i
would actually challenge you to
create some space between the stress
you're experiencing and your response
um again we want to train our response
not necessarily eliminate
the trigger which a lot of times can be
stressed and so
a lot of times has to be trained and
again we can't expect our athletes to
perform well under pressure
if we're not training them under
pressure so i think it's huge
i think it's a separator when it comes
to to performance especially with elite
performers
lauren i'm laughing because uh as you
were saying nobody ever
relaxed when you told them to relax uh i
made the mistake one time
i told only that i said you know hey
just relax and then
all of a sudden everything got ratcheted
up a little bit and i was like all right
that was good feedback that will not be
that i use again
do a mental note on that one yeah i'm
well trained on that uh i'm avoiding
that exact phrase from now on
we've talked a lot about uh kind of i
think adults in general as business
investing or
professional athletes um i saw a couple
of questions that people had around
how does this apply to kids especially
if you're the parent of a child um
the questions were really around kind of
like kids in sports but maybe we can
just talk about it broadly
uh is it something where like will you
screw up your kid if you try to make
them mentally tougher by like doing
exercises or like intentionally putting
them in certain stressful situations
or is it actually a positive thing and
it's like hey look you know you should
start almost conditioning or training
your child from a
mental strength and mental resilience
standpoint uh at a young age like how do
you look at almost like the
child development around some of this
stuff and how intentional people should
be versus
uh just let it naturally happen yeah
that's a really great question
first of all i would recommend uh people
to check out the book parent pep talks
by my friend justin sua
great book it kind of teaches the parent
about mental toughness and then gives
really great exercises for you to
execute with your child so
really really great book highly
recommend um and so yes you can totally
train your kid um starting at a young
age but
i think what a lot of people mistake
that as
is is that we're just going to push them
really hard and
we're going to put them in really tough
situations now yes and no
i think one of the biggest thing pieces
of advice well people ask me and
now while i don't have kids i can i've
seen what it looks like on the other
side meaning when these things
aren't implemented what it looks like at
the pro level when we draft them
and one of the biggest things i tell
parents is
let your kid fail
let them fail i've seen what it looks
like when they've never failed before
and they get to the pro level
it's not pretty and it's it's a huge and
very steep
learning curve and so i would say that
you know if your kid doesn't bring
their water bottle to practice don't
bring it to them
they're not going to die they'll
probably ask somebody for a sip of their
water
and they'll be embarrassed to do so and
that may be the very thing that will
motivate them to remember oh crap i
gotta bring my water bottle
you know there's those little things and
so i wouldn't say that you need to go
out to the field and
put them under all this stress and make
them feel insanely uncomfortable to
where they hate it
the point is for them to enjoy it and to
teach them how to cope with the natural
things that sport and life
offers us by not just trying to say it
doesn't exist and take them all away
but teaching them productive ways to
cope with it one of the things that you
can do
and actually talks about this in the
book parent pep talks is
create kind of these controllable sex
successful wins that we talked about
earlier
when you're in a slump teaching them you
know quality over just the outcome or
sorry
um the quality of what you do things
within your control
over the outcome things outside of your
control and so we can do that by
creating a visual of this a lot of our
improvements can't be seen immediately
right when you go out and you go to the
gym for five
hours you're still not fit when you walk
out right
we get fit over time and so even by
creating like even a jar
and every time they they do that one
thing they said they were gonna do
within their control
put a marble in the jar over time it's
gonna be a great visual and
there's something about either putting a
marble in the jar
or exiting off on the calendar that is
insanely motivating because
there's nothing more motivating than
seeing ourselves make progress
and so that's a great way when we want
to make progress in something that
doesn't
isn't immediately visual is to create a
visual around it
yeah i love that um two more questions
for you before
we go to wrap up uh the first is just
what's the craziest thing that you've
had to do
with a client no names but what's the
absolute craziest thing you had to do to
either get them to
break out of a slump or overcome some
sort of mental hurt
whatever the thing that you just thought
that's the one you should definitely say
okay well i'm just like it's i don't
even know if i have anything like
incredible for you um i'm trying to
think
craziest craziest craziest um
i mean i've there are a couple things um
i've gotten calls in the middle of the
game
which they should not have phones um
and you know something happened on the
field and
he got thrown out of a game and ran into
the locker room and called van was in a
very heated very frustrated
understandably so and but it was
like that was not an easy situation to
handle
because there was a lot of moving pieces
there but um
i've i've been on like you know i'm
watching the game
and so when i'm getting up call i'm like
what like why am i getting this call
um because it happened in the dugout and
the camera wasn't on the dugout so i
didn't see it
um so that was that was really
interesting but um in terms of crazy
you know i don't think they necessarily
like i don't have these
insanely crazy stories i think the most
the most
i don't know it's crazy as they come are
actually pretty human
in terms of when we get to the core
of something that is really upsetting to
somebody or the core of something that
you would have never thought that was
the reason behind this action
and i'll give you an example i had um
you know i within our system you know
the other mental coaches you know in in
the medical conditioning department
could probably attest to this as well
we know all of our guys like very very
well like if somebody
walked in to a room of all of our guys
in our system
we would either be like we either got
even a trade and we haven't heard about
it yet
or like you shouldn't be here like we
know every single person that well
and i was at an affiliate and there was
this one guy in particular that
for whatever reason it was really short
with me whenever i would ask him a
question you know we're in the dugout
with them and like you know not all the
time talking about mental toughness
we're talking
just shooting the [ __ ] talking about
whatever and
this kid was just really avoidant like
and i knew him really well
and was like answering with really short
sentences
and i thought it was really odd so i i
immediately i take the blame and i go
maybe i haven't developed a good enough
relationship so i'm going to spend more
time trying to develop that and it's man
it's like no matter
how much attention i would try and give
that relationship it was like kept
getting shut down
so i thought man maybe i maybe i said
something
you know i'm not sure but i wanted to
get to the bottom of it because
um because i've worked with this kid
before so i just want to make sure i
didn't offend him in any way
so i went up to him and i actually got
to the batting cages early and he uh
he he was the only person there so i
think it was like his worst nightmare
and i walk up and i said you know hey do
you mind if i ask you a question he's
like yeah
he said um you know i i every time i try
and talk to you you've been really short
like
you know have i said something to offend
you or is there is there a reason
for that um and he's like well
not necessarily like i'm it's not
because like you haven't said anything
you know to offend me or anything like
that
i'm like okay so um what do you think it
is
and he kind of quietly goes you know
well
i just don't think i'm very good at
speaking so
whenever somebody of authority talks to
me i just try not to speak
and i was like interesting so he met
with me a couple days later to kind of
dive a little bit more into it
and what we ended up finding was that in
first grade
his teacher told him he's not good at
speaking
ever since then he has avoided speaking
and so the way i like to break this down
is that our beliefs
plus our actions drive our identity
he believed he wasn't good at speaking
every time he didn't speak that action
it solidified this identity that i'm not
good at speaking
that was built in that habit was built
in since first grade
and we were like i was like whoa and so
i think that was crazy to think because
i would have never guessed that here i
am so self-absorbed thinking like
it's me and it's and he's
he's dealing with this kind of like
inner battle with something that
happened in first grade
and so the way that we work through
these things is we take the identity we
just work it backwards we take the
identity what what kind of person do you
want to become and he's like i want to
be the person that isn't afraid to speak
in a big group setting
and i was like great well then what
action do we need to cert
do we need to insert there to solidify
that identity so that your belief
catches up with that
and he goes i need to talk more
right yep and so that's how we
restructured
and rebuilt this new belief of himself
is taking this identity of who we wanted
to become
and we supported it with daily actions
that then solidified and created this
belief and in that situation
is the kind of like homework coming out
of that conversation like hey i want you
to go up to three strangers every day
and go talk to them is it
hey next time that the entire team's in
the locker room i want you to stand up
and say something
um is it kind of like very tactical
specific
type of you know homework i guess or
kind of assignment or is it more so just
hey you need to now think of yourself as
somebody who enjoys speaking and so when
the opportunity presents itself like
we'll leave it up to you but you need to
speak more
and then you trust the um athlete to
kind of
you know actually put it into practice
um i'd say a little bit of both
with him in particular i wanted to hold
him accountable and he asked me to
so what we actually did is i set him up
for success in our meeting so when we
had group sessions
i would prompt him with the question
before the meeting even started
and asked him if it was okay if i called
on him and so what we did by doing that
it started out that he was i was putting
him in a position to succeed
so that then over time he got really
comfortable being in front of people and
saying things because he was getting
positive reinforcement
because it's not like i was calling on
him in the middle of nowhere with a
question he wasn't ready to
talk about it was i was setting him him
up for that
and over time it really it got easy to
where the point he didn't need a
prompted question
he was raising his hand and he was
contributing like everybody else
yeah it's amazing how uh by changing the
identity and then just
again the persistent and consistent
activity of uh reinforcing it can really
have an
impact um one last thing i want to talk
about before we do the rapid fire to
finish
up is uh kind of external forces so
we've talked a lot about kind of
internally what you can do uh your
identity
your actions um kind of everything that
i would consider natural
and internal um i saw a bunch of
questions people had around
external courses so everything from like
micro dosing
all the way to uh like almost having a
daily coach that kind of you know
positive talk to you or whatever how do
you
view the internal versus the external
like are there external things that
you're like yep we think that these
things are really valuable
and like we recommend them a lot to uh
clients or
is it more so like a lot of that stuff
is maybe not gimmicks but just
um it can supplement the real work which
is more of the internal
and kind of the uh almost like
self-motivated type work that you've got
to do
uh if you want to improve some of this
stuff yeah there's um
one of the biggest things that i truly
believe in is like
your environment is kind of like the
invisible hand that shapes
a lot of our behaviors and there was
actually a study done
um at a hospital where they wanted to
increase
the amount of water sales and decrease
the amount of soda
that was being sold in these sugary
drinks and
all they did they didn't tell people
they wanted them to buy more water they
didn't promote more water
all they did was they changed the
location of the water
in the cafeteria of this hospital in
over three months time
they increased water sales by i think
eleven percent and decreased uh soda
sales by a ton
and so just by simply changing their
environment and i think that's one of
the things
i call it like kind of functioning your
habits is that we we
change kind of um james clear also talks
about this is that
when there's a lot of friction meaning
there's a lot of things you have to do
in order to execute a habit
the less likely you're going to so when
we can simplify that as best as possible
make it easier to do the good habit and
more difficult to do the bad one
what we're doing is we're really
designing our habits in our environment
in a way that's going to support the
things that we want to do
without motivation for instance like in
the
if i have to wake up really early in the
morning i
don't even allow myself to have the
option of hitting snooze
i put my phone across the room and i
turn it up to the nth degree
because it's now easier for me to get up
and turn it off
than it is to lay in bed and ignore it
and so
when we can kind of flip our habits by
changing or sorry flip our environment
to support the good habits and make the
good ones easy and the bad ones
difficult
what we're doing is we're changing our
environment in a way that
that requires less motivation to take
action we're removing the friction from
that
so another example of that is um
is if you're if you want to watch less
tv like take the
batteries out of the remote it only
takes 10 seconds to put them back in but
you're adding friction
if you if that doesn't work then unplug
the tv
if that doesn't work you take it off the
wall and put it in the closet again all
that setup only takes five minutes
but well depending on the size tv you
have i guess
but um what you're doing is you're
making the
the good habit easy which is not
watching tv and the bad habit more
difficult so
i think that we can really use
environment design to really support our
habits and our daily actions
um every day yeah and you know in the
kind of mobile social world right
literally seeing people just say hey
look i'm gonna shut off notifications
right or i'm gonna delete it
from my phone we'll use it on desktop or
whatever so i definitely think that uh
that applies to everyone's life for uh
whatever they're trying to accomplish
um before we wrap up i always ask
everyone the same two questions and
you'll get to ask me one to
finish up the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
most important book um can't hurt me by
david goggins
hands down one of my favorites he is a
uh
a very special person especially when it
comes to this stuff
very what do you think the biggest thing
you learn from him is
um i think that it's just
this idea that like you can override
your default settings no matter where
you're
where your starting line is and so i
think for me like he's such a good
example of that
is that there are these default settings
but it's all it takes is
sometimes a mindset shift um to be able
to do that not easy
it's it's sometimes it's simple but a
lot of times isn't easy so i think it's
just overriding the defaults yeah that's
fantastic
uh the second question is more fun uh
aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer believer
why i think it's crazy to i
i think it would be wild to believe that
we are the only things that exist
in just the universe i think that it
would be
i don't know i just don't i don't know
that's that's that's really all i've got
like i don't have anything else behind
it except that i think it's wild to
think that we are the only
life on earth or like on in this
universe
i agree with you uh i i don't know if
there's green men showing up but
uh there's definitely intelligent life
somewhere yeah
it's too big so we're we see eye to eye
on that um you can ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
oh i want to know what
is what has been your biggest obstacle
what was your biggest obstacle and i've
kind of two a two-part question biggest
obstacle
and greatest takeaway from 2020.
um the biggest obstacle uh i was very
fortunate in this scenario so it's easy
for me to talk about because
uh i kind of was able to sidestep it so
uh i was in the military deployed
overseas to iraq in
2008 2009 and when i came back
this is right about the time where uh
the military
started to really understand like oh
shoot like maybe we're not doing a great
job of helping people transition back
uh and there's lots of ptsd and and kind
of just the the mental scars
of sending young people to war um
and so i always say that like i kind of
had a escalation
and a de-escalation uh from a mental
perspective in that
i went from being a you know regular
person to
i was playing college football i got
deployed in the june in my junior year
of college
uh and so i went from this environment
of like all dudes
you literally like put a uniform on and
then you go to a quote-unquote like
combat on a football field and so like
really physically running into each
other's very testosterone heavy
uh kind of competitive environment to
then like i went to war
and like same thing lots of dudes you
know
uniforms testosterone heavy combative
type environment
just there's guns and you know there's
no whistles or timeouts or anything like
that
when i came back most of the people who
had been deployed with
they went back to their jobs literally
like there was people i knew that were
law enforcement prison guards uh one guy
worked at a hardware store
another guy literally was a fish and
wildlife you know park ranger
like all of these guys were going back
to kind of normal day jobs they were
going back to live with their wives and
their kids to pay their mortgage
and it's just a very kind of um i think
disruptive experience to kind of live
your life go deployed uh
come back and not have that
de-escalation as well
and so for me i went back and i had the
opportunity uh to finish playing
football
and so again it went from like a
semi-combative type environment to
war back into that semi-combative
environment and then back to kind of
being a normal person that wasn't
playing
a competitive sport and so i always
credit
uh that transition there was no master
plan i didn't understand that that's
what was happening but in hindsight i
think that really helped me kind of
transition
back was uh you know they kind of took
the guns away but there was still the
uniform there was still that
testosterone-driven combative
type environment um and so i think a lot
about like
uh everything is relative right of like
yeah sure i went back
into kind of the normal world it's just
the environment i went into
was probably much more advantageous for
me than if i had just been a
21 year old kid who just got thrown back
into the real world
um you know i was already doing some
pretty stupid stuff in terms of you know
bought a motorcycle and go 100 miles an
hour and say well you know find a diet
war like you know whatever here
but uh having that transition i think
was really helpful
um and then for 2020 uh
i think that really the thing that um
kind of just got hammered home is like
nobody knows the future
like literally nobody knows the future
and it seems like every time
uh something crazy happened it'd be like
oh man how much crazier could it get
and then like literally like within 12
hours like something even crazier would
happen
um and so if you even look at like 20 21
i think a lot of people have this like
psychological
okay we made it through 2020 like take a
deep breath like it's over
and there was definitely this like
turning of the page and then like we're
six seven days into 2021 now we're like
wait a minute is 2021 gonna be even
wilder than last year
um and so it's just like you can't
control the stuff and a lot of what you
started off the conversation around just
like your ability to adapt to
uh the things that happen are really
important um
and uh i'll leave you with this one
controversial topic that i've talked
about
online uh ad nauseam and people hate
when i say this
uh but i say it because it's true is i
don't believe in luck
and when i say that people are like what
do you mean you don't believe in luck
and i say well
we confuse the mathematical concept of
randomness with the psychological
concept of luck and i always use the
extreme example of like
if somebody goes to war and they lose
their arm and leg
a lot of people be like man that was
really unlucky but if you talk to that
person they'll say
no i'm lucky like i'm alive and so luck
is really
a mental perspective on an event that
happened
right the reason why that person lost
their arm and leg
there's a sense of randomness right are
they the one who sat in that seat versus
somebody else are they the one that was
in that vehicle versus a different
vehicle right
um and so i think that when you start to
really unpack kind of the mathematical
concept from the psychological concept
you realize and there's studies that
show like you actually can change your
luck
simply by changing the way you view the
events that happen
sounds really stupid sounds like oh of
course then why aren't we all lucky all
the time
but i do think that there's you know a
lot of truth in that and so it kind of
just puts you back in the control seat a
little bit and say look you can't
predict the future you can't control the
things that
uh happen but you can control how you
respond to them and i think that that's
kind of
you know really what it sounds like you
spend most of your day trying to hammer
home to a lot of these athletes and
clients like
exactly like it couldn't i couldn't even
say it better myself i think
you know just to like round all that out
that mental toughness
it doesn't make you invincible it makes
you adaptable it makes you
it allows you to see things from
different perspectives
when you get dealt a crappy hand of
cards you have the opportunity to see it
one way or the other way
when my parents got divorced i could
have you know when i look back i
you could i could tell you how horrible
it was and all the bad things but i can
also tell you all the good things that
came from it
you know that every every bad moment we
can learn something from and i think all
that comes down to is this power of
choice that we have
and that's what i think mental toughness
provides is it provides us more choices
and more
uh choices to adapt versus just to i
guess
fall victim to some of the default
settings absolutely
makes a ton of sense um where can we
send people to find you on the internet
i know you've been creating a ton of
content
uh you've got a newsletter that's coming
out uh where do we want to send them
to uh to find you and learn more about
some of the work that you're doing
so you can find me on instagram and when
i got married last year i changed my
name from a barca which was my maiden
name
to now johnson turns out there's a lot
of lauren nicole johnson's in this world
so
all my handles are different um i wish
they weren't but
my instagram handle pay attention is
laura nicole johnson
uh twitter is at underscore lauren
johnson
underscore and you can find me on
linkedin and i just
um shout out to ari lewis for uh
inspiring me to get a tick tock
um it's at lauren johnson with an
extra n at the end i believe okay good
luck okay i got it
uh when you create content what platform
do you think first to post it is it
instagram
twitter twitter yeah i twitter and
linkedin actually
those are my those are my top two and
then i usually go instagram and then
and then tick talk and and like you said
i am
in the in the midst of creating a
newsletter and so if you want to sign up
for that ahead of
time you can at any of my links on my
twitter and my instagram and my link
tree
awesome all right well listen i really
really appreciate this lauren i think
people are going to learn a ton from it
so
thanks so much for doing a lot to do to
get in the future yeah i'd love that
thanks for having me